we began this half-hour with an effort
to reopen one of the holiest sites in
Christianity it's a spot on the west
bank of the Jordan River where Jesus is
believed to have been baptized it's been
inaccessible to pilgrims for over 50
years because the site is planted with
landmines but as Jonathan Vigliotti
reports on this Easter weekend an effort
is now underway to make the site safe
every year hundreds of thousands of
Christians dip into the Jordan River for
baptism ceremonies yards away
ghostly churches monasteries and chapels
marked the site where Christians believe
Jesus himself was baptized for decades
this stretch of land holy to Christians
Muslims and Jews has been off-limits
until now these men are making a
different kind of pilgrimage the Israeli
defense ministries National Mine Action
Authority and a British charity are
hunting for landmines I think it's
pretty dangerous
James Cowan with the halo Trust says
around 3,000 mines dot roughly 250 acres
of holy land anti-tank mines
the size of a small pizza are buried not
all are visible to the naked eye the
really insidious thing about landmines
is that whilst the the reasons for them
being laid in the past may disappear the
landmines themselves remain just as
lethal long into the future
they are the deadly leftovers from the
arab-israeli war and the decades of
conflict that followed for the last 60
years nearly it's been impossible to
reach the churches and so we've worked
with the Christian denominations we work
with the Israeli authorities and we work
with the Palestinians to get permission
to start work to clear all the explosive
hazards from around the churches it's an
unlikely team effort in a region still
divided by conflict the over 1 million
dollar project will clear mines using
diggers and metal detectors then clear
the churches which are believed to be
booby-trapped
mine's will be detonated like these
gathered from other sites the hope is
people can step foot on this resurrected
ground by next Easter what is now a
desert will be turned into a vibrant
place in which pilgrims and tourists can
come to be baptized and to visit the
site where by tradition Christ was
himself baptized for CBS this morning
Saturday Jonathan Vigliotti London